This is Ian Sherr for the Wall Street Journal in San Francisco.
We've heard from some of the component suppliers in Asia that...
...as many as 10 million units of the smaller tablet that Apple is building...
...are gonna be built during the fourth quarter.
What we know so far is that it's a 7.85-inch screen diagonally,...
...which is smaller than the 9.7-inch screen diagonally that the iPad is right now.
We also know that the screen will be a lower resolution.
What we don't know yet is the release date,...
...and we also don't know what the price will be.
There's a lot of competition right now...
...and pressure on Apple to release a smaller and also cheaper tablet,...
...and that's what a lot of the analysts are expecting.
But of course, this is Apple, we don't know for sure.